لاول مره منذ سبعين سنه الهند تصبح اكبر
دوله في العالم من حيث عدد السكان وتتجاوز
الصين المتصدره منذ بدايه التعداد عام
1950 على عكس الصين لم تنجح الهند في
تحديد النسل رغم انها اول بلد يتبنى هكذا
سياسه عام 1952
تحديد النسل تضمن حبلات تعقيم ركزت على
النساء ولم تلقى قبولا من الرجال الرجال
يرفضون التعقيم اي قطع القناه الدافئه او
القناه المنويه وهو اجراء لا يستغرق عشر
دقائق لانهم يعتقدون بانهم سيصابون بالعجز
الجنسي بل يعتقد البعض انهم سيصبحون اضعف
جسديا في المقابل تنتشر مراكز تعقيم
النساء في المناطق الريفيه وهي عمليه لا
تخلو من المخاطر وتستغرق نحو 50 دقيقه
لربط قناه فالوب
بحسب منظمه بوكيوليشن فاونديشن فان النساء
يتعرضن لضغوط من قبل العاملين الصحيين
الحكوميين للخضوع للعمليه مع تعويض مالي
يعادل 22 يورو
تعتقد هذه المنظمه لانه يجب زياده الوعي
تجاه الترويج لحبوب منع الحمل واقناع
الرجال بالخضوع للتعقيم فالواضح ان
التركيز على تعقيم النساء لا يحقق النتائج
المرجوه فهل يبدي الرجال استعدادا لقطع
القناه الدافئه ولماذا يترددون برايك
[موسيقى]